Some of the exercises in this
course will require the use
of a wonderful tool called Mathquill.
Mathquill is an equation editor,
which means that it allows us to type
things that normal keyboards don't
usually allow, like exponent.
To type an exponent in
Mathquill you use a caret.
Let me show you on my keyboard.
This is a caret, so to get this,
I would hold down Shift and
hit the 6, but
your keyboard might be different.
Still, most keyboards will
have a caret on them.
So to type x to the sixth,
what you would need to
type would be x caret six.
After you type the caret,
you'll see your cursor move up into
the superscript area, and then you
can proceed typing your exponent.
To type something after the exponent
you would hit the right arrow key.
So that's what it looks
like on my keyboard.
So after you hit the right arrow key,
the cursor will then return
to the normal position,
out of the superscript position,
and you can continue typing.
So for example,
if you wanted to type x squared y,
what you would hit would be x caret 2,
right arrow key, y.
Now you try entering these yourself, and
here are a couple of other expressions
for you to try and practice as well.
Try using Mathquill to type
out x cubed y squared plus 4z,
as well as 7a squared b- c to the fifth,
and enter your answers in the boxes.